former Florida State Travis rudolph is
on trial for murder his alleged
girlfriend
attacked him and then proceeded to text
her brother to also Target Rudolph when
her brother and Friends showed up one of
them was gunned down and killed so let's
watch some of the Court transcripts
because they actually have video of this
I want you guys to just listen to
portions
[Music]
that was her texting the other saying go
go shoot up his side isn't it true that
you were the first person to become
physically violent when Travis with
Travis and not the other way around
no not at all
something or show me something if I
can't recall the exact
steps of the moments
you remember that yes so you smashed his
iPhone not out of anger but because you
were hurt yes and I didn't send my
brothers to kill him
so shoot up his [__] right I didn't say
shoot him
so first she lied on the stand saying
she doesn't uh starting to [__] it but
when she did a police deposition she
admitted that she was the one who shoots
it and then she sold her brother's her
brother to go shoot up and [__] he's
like well I didn't tell him to go shoot
him up
just a [__]
this don't look good my girl this do not
look good
all right
[__] is
when you're angry you say things
oh to the question
what is [__] you inside
and when you are angry
you say things
that was your rebuttal
uh
[Music]
girl no foreign
now imagine all the people that did
stuff because they're angry
you know what
hold on
yeah
we can understand why you feel a certain
way
that does not excuse the actions that
you're gonna do afterwards you can be
angry get it concur
but it does not excuse what you do with
your body means put your hands on
someone or what comes out of your mouth
watch yourself before you break yourself
I thought that we've established the
fact that
anger was not an issue the anger was not
a reason to say things right that's what
they put on us
now you pull you pull this uh well you
know I just said that like I said that
no because guess what happened
your brother did that
when they're in the intent of shooting
[__] up and if I see that happening that
person coming to me I'm defending myself
I got mad that's so excuse
I'm sure everyone in this courtroom has
said something when you're I'm trying to
speak if you want me to answer your
question you have to let me answer your
question well if you were responsive to
my question I would not all right answer
the question please okay can you repeat
your question question was [__] what
does [__] mean in the context of that
text
okay so it could have been his brother
no
house nothing violent
toward a person it could have been his
mother's how in your head
is shooting [__] up
not violence that's besides me I don't
understand that maybe you go up to the
house you're like hey guys what room are
you in third floor
second room to the left okay guys shoot
up every other room do you think that's
how it works
no she's she's peddling hot she's trying
to
the water is hot and she's trying to
survive you know his mother's house
right
I was upset and I my adrenaline was
running and I said something that I
didn't mean that's the bottom line of
that I didn't mean for him to do for my
brothers to do any of that that's some
of my brother left the house he did not
have a firearm on him people say things
when they're upset that they don't mean
all the time that is not true his
brother did bring a firearm uh the
claimed that they didn't want to use it
or that they never put it out but they
ended up finding the firearm in a bush
nearby
so clearly when she's going to shoot up
and [__] my man brought a Glock because
he knew what time it was and that is not
true right since the situation has
happened it obviously
blew up 20 times more but I didn't
necessarily mean for anything to happen
to Travis's family his house or anything
it's like my it was like my second home
I would not want anything to happen
there all right and he never raised a
hand and touched you did he not
yeah he was raising his hand the whole
time like grabbing me pushing me back
yeah the whole time
so he was did he punch you no he didn't
punch me did he slap you oh he didn't
slap me
objects and hit you over the head with
them no so why'd you want to smash his
car window
I like I said it wasn't intentional I
was just throwing things because I was
upset and you when you were throwing
things you were also screaming things at
them like you were going to send your
brother Keyshawn over to kill him right
never ever ever said the word kill at
all okay so
four men showed up at his front door and
you told both of them that Travis picked
you up and slammed you to the ground
right yes and that he had destroyed
here's a sad part in all this
one dude is potentially going to jail
for the rest of his life for murder
her brother is dead
all because
she's a liar and a manipulator
and she's gonna Escape all this
scot-free
she told her brother that he beat her
and that he [__] her up or whatever so
of course the brother's natural response
to want to defend his sister he believed
her lies about the whole violent stuff
and he was going to their Defender and
that's why he brought other people with
him but that's just wasn't the case it
just wasn't true and
this guy's seeing four Dudes roll upon
his doorstep possibly with guns because
she told him they won't shoot his place
up
just wanted them in self-defense and
ends up being scarred for life even if
he gets off free and also potentially
facing a murder charge because of all
this you got to be careful who you bring
into your life man
because some of these women even though
they might not be violent they might be
infinitely worse for your life
sometimes you rather get punched and
have to deal with some [__] like this
because even though they might not be
they might know people who will do stuff
against you and so now you're dealing
with a situation that's infinitely worse
again being up by somebody because one
woman told some lies
one's dead
and one may go to jail for the rest of
his life
just because of one person's lie so
whenever people tell you why do you take
false accusations and all this stuff
like because it could spiral into things
like this when you just believe women
now you need to believe women he
believed a sister which is sensible but
you know that's the power of Lies
anybody that
has a chance to lie will lie
whatever is because of anger
because the resentment because of
Vengeance they're gonna lie
and that's anybody
and then the concept of lying is just
saying something that is not true
sometimes they think something might
happen and they still lie and he didn't
so yeah
and you also sent a text message to
Keyshawn at roughly 9 45 that Travis
dropped you to the ground you remember
that yep and in response to that text
message Keyshawn sent a group text
message to you and Tyler Robinson that
Travis is a dead man walking is that
correct yes
and that's the message that you deleted
from your phone right no I deleted the
shoot his [__] up message and you also
deleted the dead man walking message oh
I'm not sure I don't remember if I did
or not
so you really weren't making a living as
a real estate agent right
um no but I do have a mom and she's a
medical assistant so okay and you were
living with your mom good right you had
a conversation with a man about marriage
and you're still married to Andre Chase
is that correct correct
lied to Travis you misled him did you
not Travis never asked me if I was
married
oh wow oh
so think about this
think about this think about this think
about this
she got mad at him for cheating
meanwhile she got a whole ass situation
no she got a whole ass husband
and she mad because he's involved with
somebody else
I'll say this for the 100th time guys
don't get involved with married women
make sure your girl not in no
relationship okay and two
this is my final piece of advice be very
careful who you even want to just [__]
for a jump off or whatever because I'm
telling you you [__] the wrong one and
they can [__] up your life and you're
gonna regret ever getting in that [__]
that's why the guys like I love crazy
boys I love them you love it till you
don't and when you don't you wish you
never loved it to begin with
you wish you never loved it when the
[__] showing up at your home
harassing your family making X or going
online saying a bunch of [__] even if
it's not true don't [__] matter
because it just it's messing with your
stress levels and everything else
trust me if she crazy stay the [__] away
and this girl looks like she can't hide
her crazy to be honest with you well she
probably got a fat ass or whatever it is
so he went for it
it sucks because you have to exert quite
a lot of self-control but I recommend it
so that's my advice anything else oh no
bro she got a whole ass husband that was
a good twist
I had a husband that [__] crazy
that's where you lost me
that's where you lost me no cause
when she said
that and in her rebuttal was yeah he
never asked if I had it
foreign